well we've got a big debate that's got
the whole internet buzzing and talking
and it comes from the uk
entertainment weekly reports that the
sun published a story claiming the
world's sexiest bald man
is prince william and it was a part of a
survey where
mike tyson and jason statham came in
second
and third and the internet was
immediately up in arms there were calls
for like where is the rock
common ll but the fan favorite i guess
was like stanley tucci i get the stanley
tucci thing
because he's amazing i kind of forgot
about him for a little while until he
did that cnn show where he's cooking in
italy oh i know i just want to go to
italy now i want to eat pasta he has a
nice
figure too and it's not a lascivious oh
whoa by the way i get jealous
i get jealous drew i get jealous well
gosh
you you are just a handsome man head to
toe
thank you and next yes i am very happy
and grateful to say
that i have gotten my vaccine shot
thank you i did it in jersey city with
our first lady in new jersey tammy
murphy who happens to be a uva grad like
me
and the mayor of jersey city we went
over to
encourage the minority community to not
have hesitancy
we know that once we have heard immunity
70 in our communities and across the
country
this place will be a much better world
so we're looking forward to that
happening
and i encourage everyone to go get their
shots like i have yes
now if that wasn't sweet enough the deal
just got so much sweeter i cannot wait
delish reports that krispy kreme is
giving away
a free original glazed donut to anyone
with the vaccination card and
it's not just a one-off it's every
day for the rest of 2021
oh my gosh a donut a day
does not keep the doctor away but it is
a sweet
sweet treat that i will be partaking in
yes i ran um
morning so i'm gonna have two just so
you know thank you krispy kreme
for making getting vaccinated as tikki
said even sweeter
yes it is thank you this is like
literally
i i just i just want to lie down on
it it's so beautiful it's so beautiful
well we got to talk about the ncaa
it is march madness so there has been a
ton of great basketball but there's also
been a huge conversation about
gender disparity and it all was sparked
by
sedona prince a forward for the
university of oregon when she posted
this on tick tock
so for the ncaa march madness the
biggest tournament in college basketball
for women
this is our weight room let me show you
all the men's weight room
this one really got me yeah it should so
we all know that in 1972 title ix
was passed in this country and what that
does is it prevents
sex discrimination to any educational
institution that gets federal funds
and we see this because there are equal
number of men's
scholarship teams as well as women
scholarship teams
what gets in people's craw about this
for the ncaa is it's all about money
the ncaa men's basketball tournament
makes 900 million dollars the women
makes
15. but it doesn't mean that you can't
spend the same amount of resources to
celebrate these amazing women
who are doing unbelievable things as
well i mean because this is the ncaa and
the division one council
they should know better so kudos to the
women in the ncaa tournament who won't
stand for this anymore
what sedona did was showing those
pathetic little barbells
next to the men's gym and her words
it it affected me so deeply
and she brought up the covid testing
isn't the same
the funds aren't the same the resources
but the way she did it was just
i don't know how to say this but it was
so visually compelling
and matter of fact it's like i would
hire the best filmmaker in the world and
they probably couldn't have done it
that well it's like the cynic it's like
she was a new yorker like she had the
cynic the cynicism part of that
down perfectly yeah and look women
deserve the equal amount of
attention and resources for these
massive tournaments that go on and make
the ncaa
so much money
you